Conventionally speaking, aggro is a fairly
straightforward archetype. Your opponent is at
a life total. The rules of the game say you need
to turn that life total to zero. You try to do so,
as quickly as possible. Common ways of doing
this consist of direct damage, small creatures,
large creatures rushed out quickly, and so
forth. Red Deck Wins is instructive here:
a mixture of burn spells and small creatures
means that the aggro player will try to deal
as much creature damage as possible early
and then hope that they can run the deck
to the finish line with burn. In a 20 health
format, this is straightforward and makes sense.
What about in commander though? That 120
health format we all know and love. A mere
39 lightning bolts are needed, presuming
each player gutshots themself with a land.
Or 39 swings with a Delver of Secrets, if you
prefer. Or 13 swings with an elite squad of
three Delvers of Secret. Hmmm. Perplexing. The
answer is that it doesn’t work. The fact that
EDH is a 40 life format is a pain point for our
hypothetical red-deck-winner. With this in mind,
I think an instructive exercise is to
think about what that 40 life really means.
First of all, lifepay is so much less punishing.
Fetches and shocks? Easy. Phyrexian mana symbols?
Close enough to free. Paying 1 life for
1 card? An even more delicious bargain
than usual. These effects, worthwhile but
noticeably painful in a 20 health format,
are now nearly painless. Secondly, blocking
isn’t as necessary. Decks are empowered to
constantly use tap abilities, to swing in
for value with a Bident of Thassa effect,
and to eat 5-10 damage hits rather than blocking
with an important creature. They’re also empowered
to spend their early turns throwing down snowbally
value cards rather than committing much to board.
So, with that stuff in mind—what happens if
you remove that extra health and take away
those things? Suddenly that Phyrexian Arena is a
liability. That Dismember is close to regaining
its status as a three mana black card. Your
commander might need to be a blocker if you
didn’t add enough creatures to your deck, and
trading is the best case scenario. Spending a turn
playing setup cards for an approaching big turn
goes from an exciting proposition to a terrifying
one when you might be the one to get knocked out
if you skimp on blockers. Your hands are tied,
your knees are quivering, and your deck
decidedly was not built for this situation.
To me, this is the best starting point for looking
at EDH aggro. Your goal doesn’t start and end
with reducing your opponent’s life total to zero
like it generally does in 20 health 1v1 formats,
because cutting out a large chunk of an
opponent’s life total is helpful in its
own right. My mantra in a game where somebody
has a deck that is concerning and unpredictable
but not necessarily totally dominant, is that they
should be at 15 life. When somebody is at 15 life,
they have to play much more conservatively.
Having safe setup turns isn’t a given,
and they’re generally one round of attacks away
from death if they start doing concerning things.
Going forward, I’m going to refer to this concept
as Aggro Ideology. This is not the beginning and
end of what aggro means in EDH, but simply
a phrase I use to gesture at the benefits of
having opponents who are scared about their life
total. If I had to pick out a second feature of
the commander format that’s important for aggro
decks, it’s commander damage. If your commander
deals 21 combat damage to an opponent, they lose.
This means that if your deck is commander based,
you’re playing a 21 health format instead of the
much more challenging 40 health format. Neat! Now,
aggro ideology and commander damage aren’t
mutually exclusive, nor do you need both.
For a summary of what decks care about
what things, this is a handy diagram.
Outside the circles, we have decks that
lose. There may be effective aggro decks
that don’t use commander damage and don’t take
advantage of disrupted opponents, but they are
exceedingly rare. On the right here, we have pure
voltron. This is a deck that plays a commander,
buffs it and protects it through a combination
of other cards, and kills players very quickly in
large bursts of damage. The higher level an aggro
list is, the more voltron-y it will be, generally
speaking. In the middle here is pseudo-voltron.
These decks will commonly utilize commander damage
to win, but will often have other forms of damage
as well. This gives the deck multiple win plans,
as well as allowing for both focused kills and
general table beatdown, which may have different
use-cases depending on what you’re playing
against. The last type of deck here is disruptive
aggro. This is a deck that fully commits to the
plan of making its opponents uncomfortable. You’ll
commonly see lots of cards that damage multiple
opponents, often paired with some form of stax.
I’ve included links to examples to each of
these types of decks in the description.
Now that I’ve laid out a conceptual foundation
for aggro, let’s talk about the specific goals
and challenges that are important within
a game. For a creature-based aggro deck,
the basic idea is simple: you want creatures
on board, and you want them to connect with
your opponents’ life totals. To connect with life
totals, you need to get past blockers. The most
common way of going about this is evasion, either
innately on the aggressive creatures or applied
through equipments or cards such as Wonder. An
alternative method is eliminating those blockers,
but this is much less common—one example is
a budget Rakdos discard deck I built that
runs Malfegor as the commander mostly
as a way of clearing out blockers.
Maintaining creatures on board is a separate
challenge, with the roadblock there usually being
boardwipes. There’s no one foolproof solution to
this, but here are some potential workarounds.
For one, be faster than the deck
with the boardwipes, and target
them first. This is likely the preferred
method for higher power voltron decks.
Alternatively run protection
spells—permanent-based is preferable
for an aggro deck, with Selfless Spirit
being the absolute gold standard if you’re
running white. You can also run instants that
protect your creatures, or even counter-spells,
but keep in mind that holding up mana will make
your deck less mana efficient unless you have
treasures or unless your creatures have flash.
As a third option, run Blood Artist effects—this
is my preferred strategy when playing black, as
it ties in beautifully with our Aggro Ideology.
The point about outrunning boardwipes ties
into a broader point about the speed of a
deck. Speed and resilience are factors
that need to be considered—a deck that
can outrun most combos and kill midrange
before it stabilizes might not need much
in the way of counterplays or resilience
to obstacles, but a slower deck might want
a lot more of those things. However, putting
those things in a deck also tends to slow it
down more, so it’s a balancing act. My Liesa
hatebears deck is a good example of slower,
more resilient aggro deck that is constantly
chewing on life totals but whose reliably
brutal commander and high density of stax mean
it doesn’t necessarily need to win super early.
Past the basics, a key skill you’ll want
to develop is target prioritization. If
your deck prefers to kill one player at a
time, you need to pick a player to focus,
and picking wrong might lose you the game.
Primary targets that come to mind are players
who pay a lot of life, and players who have
especially strong ways to shut you down,
but it’s definitely a vibes-based thing and when
in doubt you can just attack the opponent you’re
most afraid of. A final challenge I’ll mention
is that at some tables, aggro is considered rude
in some capacity. This is especially common
in pods populated with fiddly midrange decks,
where knocking a player out early means
they’ll spend upwards of an hour sitting
on the sidelines. These environments
are not my preferred one to play in,
but ultimately they simply stem from the
fact that EDH is a social game played in
a lot of different ways. The kiddie gloves
fiddly version of it is one way it’s played,
but you can certainly try to smack a little
variety into your playgroup with a beatdown deck.